lindsay jackson who lost her mother to
covid and is part of the covid uh
bereaved families for justice group
thank you very much uh lindsay for
being with us and i just wonder first of
all we've just heard from boris johnson
and he says he's paid the fine and he's
apologized is is that enough for you
no
not in the slightest
what do you think
he and rishi sunak should do
they should resign
they're not ordinary citizens
maybe paying the fine is what ordinary
citizens should have done and then moved
on with their lives but these aren't
ordinary citizens these are the two most
senior members of her majesty's
government
time was when the occupant of number 10
downing street and number 11 downing
street commanded respect
and were
people to be counted with
that's all gone hasn't it i mean this is
a nonsense to be breaking the very rules
that they made
and that the rest of us follow
deciduously
assiduously is
is
beyond ridiculous it's disgraceful
it's disgraceful that johnson in
particular lied to parliament
lied to the british people for all those
months
and now he's found out and he thinks and
and the police to give them their due
have shown no favor
and have fined him
and what is his response and apology
little boys get away with apologizing
like that as no doubt he did when he was
a little boy he's 56 years old he is the
prime minister of this country
he can't just apologize for breaking his
own rules and carry on as if nothing's
happened
i'm sorry it's not
so so what he is saying lindsay is that
it and i quote it did not occur to me
that it was a breach of the rules that's
what he's saying
so i mean what can we make of that not
only is the man a liar
he's stupid
you know when you go to a party
he knows the rules it even said no more
than two people can he not count
it's just it's ridiculous it's beyond
ridiculous he needs to go he needs to
summon up an ounce of moral fiber
and realize that his time is up this
country deserves better
far better so
clearly the rules of the laws in
question no longer exist
but there were
so many people in the country who
followed them
to the letter did not have parties
certainly but more seriously much more
seriously you know missed funerals were
unable to see their
loved ones in their in their last
moments just tell us your story i gather
your mother
passed away in april 2020 and
tell us you know what you could not see
your tell us what happened
my mum had dementia
and
by december
2019
we couldn't manage at home
anymore her dementia had deteriorated
such that we needed 24 7 care and
i found a lovely place for my mom to
live very caring people a small home
she moved in there just before christmas
2019. and she caught covered at the
start of april just a few months later
she died a week after that
i wasn't able to see my mom
for the last month of her life
i wasn't able to be with her when she
had covered and when she died
i wasn't able to
pay my respects to her body that wasn't
permitted
she wasn't able to wear her own clothes
she was sealed in a bag
there were seven of us at her funeral
i wasn't able to hug my own brother
at the end of the funeral
we just went our own ways
because we followed the rules
and
the most personally damaging aspect
of what johnson had done
is that i now feel i let my mum down
i should have been there with her
i should have had
the temerity to break the rules and be
with my mom when she needed me
i think
that would have been a more important
reason for breaking the rules
than going to a damn party
but
lindsay look clearly you did not let
your mother down those were
those were
the rules at the time i mean i just
wonder
and take your time
because i know this is very difficult i
just wonder
the people now who are saying some tory
mps we've had on are saying look it's
time to move on from this what
what would you say to them
i'm sorry there seems to be some kind of
bout of childishness breaking out
amongst the ranks of the tory party
it seems
that you just have to say oh i'm really
sorry i didn't i didn't i didn't know it
was a party to get away with it
and it also seems as though you can just
say we need to move on and woof there's
covid gone
they're crazy
350 people died last weekend of covid
350 sets of families are bereaved
as of this weekend because of covid just
wishing covid away
and wanting to move on does not make it
so believe me there is no one
more than me who would like kovid to be
gone
the thought that 350 more families are
suffering today
because of covid hurts me
but you just can't wish it away it is
here it is still here people are still
dying of it and the people in parliament
and elsewhere in the country who think
we should just get on fine
let's get on but when the cup when covid
has been subdued
it's still pandemic it's still out of
control all right lindsay well listen
we've run out of time but there's a
picture on the screen just now before we
uh
cut back to that a picture of your scene
uh on the screen of your mother and uh
yeah i think i think you've done her
proud but thank you very much uh
for talking to us this evening
appreciate your time
thank you